m stop ou encore que la seule réaction
du gouvernement à une à ses
revendications depuis 18 semaines c'est
de menacer de mettre maxime eric douay
en prison je me dis qu'il ya un grave
crime dans ce but quand la seule
réaction derrière s'est dit on va
mobiliser militaire parce qu'on sent
bien que les forces de l'ordre on l'a
dit ils sont en train de cours lundi m
on voit les militaires on les envoie à
je voulais agir pour soulager des forces
de l'ordre qui sont entraînés oui parce
que c'est pour soulager les familles
seront bien sûr la protection des lieux
sensibles
oui bah oui mais sur la politique que je
faisais mais parce qu'on a besoin
d'efforts et pourquoi est ce que les
forces de l'ordre entrain crackable
parce que au lieu d'offrir une réponse
politique un problème politique on
envoie les forces de l'ordre se
retrouver face aux citoyens et essayer
de les écraser et là il ya une
difficulté qui est quand même assez
grave et qui ferait que vous entendez
vos syndicats les personnes qui
représentent devrait se lever et dire
arrêtez vous utilisez arrêtés nous
utiliser politiquement et répondait à la
crise politique a des gens normaux qui
est celle qui sévit au départ au départ
j'ai entendu qu'il y avait des
revendications
il ya des intérêts continuent on fait
aujourd'hui écuries ddd franchement je
vous dis des déclarations inacceptables
la situation est gérée jaune a changé
non non est ce que cette situation
insupportable oui et donc cette
situation elle doit avoir une réponse
politique et non pas policière et ça
c'est essentiel
et encore une fois c'est pas en menaçant
de mettre en prison des personnes qui
sont parfaitement normal qu'ils sont
engagés avec toute leur âme sans aucune
aucune tentative de profiter de la
situation contrairement à ce qu'a dit de
façon c'est normal c'est pas maxime iko
comble même c'est pas maxi nicole le
programme déchets des responsables qui
depuis 40 ans n'aurait pas le chômage de
masse qui comme vous l'avait dit entre
10000 et 15000 morts chacun et qu entre
10000 et 15000 mort froide et croit
n'oubliez pas ça et dit il c'est pas
parce que vous vous n'êtes pas exploser
le chômage ce n'est pas parce que les
sommes qu'on peut dire vous fait que
soit vous moi je suis à voir je suis
aurait savouré voudrais que les gens qui
sont au chômage
la jolie bas et je me battais pour les
gens voient déjà les jeunes qui sont je
me défende et chez les jaunes
gratuitement à tous
alors qu'anne pas 250 millions d'euros
en cinq ans pour faire ses gammes pas de
voix contre 10 dans la boutique où vous
sortez ceux qui voudraient pas du tout
mais tu dis des bêtises dimanche ses
coûts notamment donné mes plateaux après
compris ça s'annonce chaud hot & condit
qui empruntent d'équité et de justice
jusqu'à nous il faut pas poser
savais tu dis des bêtises et je vais
directement ce que j'ai dit ça tout à
l'heure vous aider à vous êtes france en
suisse parce que vous dites qui en
prenaient pas là tout va ce que tu en
campagne ici pourquoi pas moi qui
voulais être élu qui est bien cela qui
me suis engagé marc à dire des laiteries
ce nul sans but à régler comment ça vous
rend fou dit pas de vous je sais ce qui
me rend fou c'est ta connerie qui
connaît ce que j'ai dit des bêtises tu
dis des gadgets de vous vous donnez vous
avez vous parce que moi il y avait fait
que tu aies politiser la sensibilité est
crucial non je serai à fond des gens
gratuitement je retiens ça c'est très
bien bravo à toi c'est ce que je fais et
je me suis mis à les paul dont je me
souviens la france adore mais moi j'ai
été approché par des années par les en
obtenant 10 mois d'avril avec eux et
j'ai refusé et j'ai refusé pour une
seule raison parce que j'ai vu ce
système un terrain parce que j'ai fait
ces grandes écoles si on se posait comme
tout art vous me disais mais j'ai vu
toute honnêteté je vais te dire ce que
tu dis vu comment les gens juan branco
ce que tu fais là
oui et du racisme durant six 06 ans qui
réussit un joli et mais sinon je vous
dis puisque vous serez assez sensible
mais non vous n'aurez pas possible ne
fut pas moins sensible aux difficultés
je te le dis ici je serai pas d'aider
les gens dit pas de bêtise je sais très
bien ce que tu fais que défendre des
gens tu tu manges trouve ça très bien qu
est ce qui fait que quand tu dis 250
anneaux d'euros c'est bête mais c'est
vrai mais je lui dis je la mets une
façon sympa de 150 millions le contrat
cui mais je sais très bien que tout ne
va pas donc de l'année permet de filmer
non mais qu'est ce qu'on en a à [ __ ]
est ce que vous trouvez ça normal qu'ils
aient de telles sommes qu'ils soient
gagnés par des revenus qu'il y ait de
tels écarts de richesse à qui vous vous
en fichez de dire ce problème d'argent
dans ce pays et d'autres qui n'en
gagnent pas assez mais aussi entre
grands cette affaire là c'est jeudi avec
ça je suis d'accord avec toi mais voilà
mais je vais te dire un truc mais c'est
pas c'est pas en opposant les riches et
les pauvres memeo cuba qu'on va réussir
un singe en peluche finira le sujet
parce que j'irai à tuscon je veux parler
des problèmes du fait qu'il n'y a que
des personnes attendent et écoutez moi
ça ne fait mieux que des personnes qui a
brisé et qui sont et qui sont héritiers
des gens favorisés moi j'en étais un qui
soit au poste de commande dans ce pays
c'est qu'évidemment les décisions moment
voile est dans leur intérêt
ce qu'il faut c'est qu'à nouveau
l'assemblée d'un salon sert qu'à une
chose à représenter la population pas
chercher les gens compétents etc
elle représente qui est des ouvriers à
l'association qu'ils ont créée sinon les
gens sont obligés de se retrouver dans
la rue ils se sentent pas entendus il
est fini je voudrais juste et c'est pas
la france entière mais il va arriver
c'est pas ben voilà pas très bien le
dire c'est pas la france
un propos politique j'ai reçu devrait
renoncer
pas très bien à partir de seconde pour
défendre des personnes qui est chassé
bien ce que tu fais là
la voix est une belle part ils sont là
peut pas me reprocher de gagner des sous
jus de rien et je te le dis moi je suis
d'accord avec toi moi quand je vois des
inégalités comme on peut le voir tous
les jours ça me rend fou je te lis voilà
j'essaie de faire des choses à ma petite
échelle cette masse était un truc à la
petite échelle
j'aurais pu très bien de dire moi j'en
ai rien à [ __ ] ondes tous les soirs
chez moi moi je suis tranquille tu sais
je vais pouvoir aller en vacances et
aimons et mon raymond nantes ap
totalement c'est parce que j'ai envie de
faire il faut pas y répondre des
volontés individuelles
oui mais il faut pas opposer les riches
et les pauvres aussi mais c'est une
forme de radoub échange du temps là et
je n'ai jamais mais c'est parce que tu
as voulu faire
tu sais que tu sers toi dépêché à
savatan c'était à financer s'était
découvert
macronix de wikileaks s'était fait pour
financer le séisme qui sont des années
dans les classes pour les grands groupes
c'est à dire pour des personnes est plus
favorable on allait taxer l'ensemble de
la population pour financer mes costumes
analyse le contenu on peut dire cela
on va leur jouer terminé la ville évoque
les familles des relations avec roanne
se situera que toi tu es maxime de
mélissa noir sur blanc on voir à côté de
moi je voulais revenir à notre petit
rituel revient schouppe les cessonnais
revenir à notre petit échange justement
de tchité chose qu'on a eu tout à
l'heure je trouve ça très bien que tu as
des idées jaune et que je le fasse et
que tu le fasses bénévolement moi je
vais te dire c'est vrai que j'aimerais
j'ai je te dis si aucun gilet jaune qui
me reproche mais réussit bien au
contraire
j'essaie voilà ma petite échelle de dole
et voilà de les aider comme je peux tu
me sécher en train de créer une
association là et je te demande pas
d'argent je demande juste un mélange
commandes de l'argent non mais ça ne m'a
pas demandé d'argent aux plus aisés
parce que je sais qu'il ya des
inégalités coin est plus aisé comme moi
voilà deux données chaque année on
compte encore rien les impôts mais il
faut donner encore parce qu'il ya des
mecs qui sont vraiment dans la merde et
que là quand on est dans des situations
comme ça c'est à nous aussi de bouger je
te le dis les plus aisés et de dire ben
moi chaque année eh ben je vais donner
encore un peu plus parce que je peux pas
je peux pas laisser les gens dans la mer